hello everyone welcome back to the
collider youtube channel
we are here talking witch hunt right now
which i was mighty excited to see
at south by southwest 2020 but it is
finally going to premiere at south by
southwest
2021 and i have the team behind the
movie with me
hello welcome to the channel and huge
congratulations
thank you thank you all right elle i
have to come to you first with this
because
it's festival premiere a lot of people
out there do not know what witch hunt is
about so would you do the honors of
giving a brief synopsis
so which end basically it's a world very
much like our own in modern day
america but uh witchcraft is real
and it is illegal in the united states
so our story follows a family
who is helping young witches escape
persecution
and seek asylum in mexico job well done
you're going to get asked to do that
quite a bit in the next couple of days
so i'm mildly obsessed with head count
so i'm wondering what your experience
was like after that movie came out
was it fairly easy to get the momentum
needed
to get the green light on your next
feature or were there any unforeseen
challenges in getting witch hunt going
um it was fairly easy but you know
it's it's always hard getting getting a
movie made there's so many
you know different things to consider
and um
i was very fortunate that i had um the
support of a lot of creative people that
wanted to tell this story
and fantastic a fantastic cast that
just came together so organically um
so yeah i mean it rolled one really
rolled right into the other
actually um head count came out
like a few days before we started
shooting
witch hunt so that was kind of like
there's a lot going on but it was all
good
good juju to bring to set i spent about
three days in new orleans at the
overlook film festival running around
town
shouting history at people so clearly
um what is something you strove to do on
witch hunt that you didn't get to do on
head count just
in terms of i guess pushing yourself as
a director and evolving your craft
well i wanted to work with um more women
were very talented women so i got i got
to do that and also i just wanted to do
um more stunts um and we definitely
definitely did that because you know
pushing myself as a director that was
something we didn't do
a lot in head count and so um you know i
wanted to work with fire i wanted to
work with water i wanted to work with
cars and heights and we definitely uh we
have all of those in this movie
of the bunch what proved to be the most
challenging
uh water because well and and the fire
because it's you have to be safe
obviously and that makes you go a lot um
slower so you have to kind of
um think creatively on set you know if
we're going to do this a safe way
but still make it look good like how can
we shoot it in in the most
safe and interesting way uh possible
all right gideon abigail i'm coming to
you next with a i guess like a one-two
punch of
which on screen questions abigail for
you first is there anything about having
worked on sabrina
that you found coming in handy when you
stepped on set for witch hunt
i mean yes and no because i i feel like
this film is so
so much different and it's
yeah i feel like i mean yes it is
witchcraft but it's very
they're very different characters um
but i mean just the magical element the
the i guess using my imagination
in certain scenarios um
i you could say i was kind of used to
but
it definitely was a completely
different character completely different
type of um
i guess project to tackle for me so
um which is fun and it was a challenge
so i
that definitely was i'd say the case
as a big fan of that show i'm mighty
excited to see you taking more leading
roles it's about time and i'm thrilled
for you
thank you that's so sweet flipping it
around for you gideon because if i have
my uh my production
timelines right it would be a situation
where
you made this and then made the craft
legacy
yeah i actually um elle told me to
listen to
the witch wave podcast which is pamela
grossman's
um podcast she's a witch she's awesome
and i actually got to work with her
hand in hand on the craft and she taught
me a lot
more um about you know witchcraft and
just
everyday witchcraft and you know um
covens in toronto because she flew to
toronto to teach us
you know about um
casting spells and all of that it was it
was really intense i almost like don't
know how to
talk about it because it
it was incredible we did ceremonies
together
and um i definitely took a lot of you
know what i learned from her
her podcast and you know then when i met
her i was like oh my god i just did this
movie called which time i love your
podcast and i read your book
and because of l i i i did that
um but uh yeah i mean definitely working
on these two
movies has taught me so much more about
the art
of witchcraft and what it can do for
you and your everyday life and um
yeah it's pretty pretty awesome working
on these two movies
back to back is there any uh major
misconception about the art of it
in real life that you think folks out
there might
think happens another way because of the
way it's depicted on screen
i mean definitely i think that being a
witch is a lot of negative connotation
and i learned something from aaron fogel
who's an amazing witch in toronto
about women and how
um actually i forget which god i think
it was venus
um would take children into the
underworld
and um people were like why is she doing
that because the underworld
has negative connotation but actually
the underworld
is a place with mostly women and it's
all
art and music and um
just learning and enriching yourself and
i just you know i think that's funny and
how you know society is stamped being a
witch is something scary
and dark when i think you can be a witch
in
your art in in your you know if you're a
painter if you're a writer
i think you can you know conjure up
witchcraft and really anything in your
manifestations of
you know your daily life um if you have
a mantra
like cleaning your house cleansing your
space
i think there's really witchcraft in
everything and i think as a woman
when you're born you have that in you
already
it's i mean we're the creators like
actually
so it's just it kind of goes hand in
hand i always appreciate the opportunity
to learn more
of that and covering uh the craft legacy
we got to talk about that a little on
the channel too it was uh
it was a real pleasure elizabeth coming
to you now
you've worked on a few things that i
guess take kind of like a
like a sci-fi or high-concept approach
to tackling some
real world flaws obviously the purge
comes to mind and i guess revolution to
a degree
so what was it about tackling similar
ideas
but through a story about witchcraft
that appealed to you now
i think that i i feel very similar to
the way that that
gideon does i i liked the truth of it
i i like the idea that um
people are afraid of um women's wisdom
women's strength women's courage
women's empathy you know all of those
things and that absolutely
drew me in i liked that it was
something extraordinary but told
realistically
and um and i think that's kind of what
set it apart
a little bit you know i i like telling
the truth in fantastical situations but
this felt
this just felt so true the way that it
was done though the way that owl
organized it the way that um
that everyone played these roles
nothing about it felt fantastical
it felt once again that
there were a group of people being
pushed down for being extraordinary
that's what i liked about it i think
part of the grounded
nature of the film also comes from the
fact that all three of you are so good
at conveying history between characters
without
actually spelling it out so how exactly
do you make the most of any prep time
you might have had
in order for you know elizabeth and
gideon you two to establish the
mother-daughter relationship and abigail
you to establish that relationship with
echo
well i can say i fell in love with
gideon immediately it took nothing
very very easy she's incredibly easy to
love and i'll let you guys go from there
yeah i kind of feel the same way about
elizabeth i mean um
can't you just tell by like talking to
her right now like her
energy i've actually never met someone
as sweet
and i'm saying that genuinely like where
it's not
forced it's just who she is and um
yeah it she it felt like she was my mom
i was like i want her to be my mom
but no really i just i i felt
so comfortable around her and like i
wanted to learn from her
like a mother so it was very very easy
as well how about for you abigail
yeah i think it was really easy i think
i
um definitely i mean i think i showed up
to set
late like i think you guys have been
filming for a bit um
but or maybe like the second week i
don't know
um but yeah i mean i think just
immediately there's just so welcoming
and
just kind and great energy on set so
i don't think it really took much of
prep
like sitting down um and like trying to
you know let's build this relationship
so that we can get along on set like i
felt like it was just i mean we didn't
really need to do that
um because everyone was so awesome and
then little echo she's just a
cutie she's so so sweet so awesome i
definitely like
um yeah i went between scenes and stuff
we would you know talk and kind of hang
out and and
play around and stuff but um i think she
really did
like look up to you oh so in general you
know
right seeing you know
like there's in the middle of that scene
when you're listening to her play
you made me cry every single time
because there was such a tenderness
and like a fierce protectiveness in the
way that you looked after her and that
carried on to life as well
she's such a special kid i love her yes
she was really
really wonderful and i definitely felt
like i i guess i did
more and more start to feel a little bit
of like a protective
bigger like older sister towards her
because especially like you see a little
i def i mean i kind of looked like her
when i was young too and i
almost felt like i was looking at my
little
tender self and just i don't know being
like just don't
don't get hurt by the world don't change
you know it's and
little redhead and you know i like to
ask her all about her little
redhead stories and you know struggles
and bullying and stuff and i just loved
to be able to hang out with her and you
know
because i wish i could have had that at
that age
you know but yeah everyone was amazing i
feel like there wasn't much
it was just easy you know and that makes
for such great chemistry on screen and
just a great work environment
so so now it's the uh
the make l blush portion of the
interview because again i'm a big fan of
head count i'm so excited about witch
hunt and i want her to get all the
opportunities that she wants after this
one so
what is something that elle did on set
as a leader that you wish that more
directors would
bring to their productions out there i
will
say this i think so many things
i think that l um i mean
you just carried yourself with such
grace um
and empathy and patience and
kept your cool you never once i don't
know if i even saw
you like i don't even know like
sweat like you were honestly just you
just knew exactly what you wanted
and you got it done and i've never seen
someone so
calm cool calm and collected get things
done so well like
you walk into a room and everyone's just
like there she is what do you want my
queen
like honestly because you're so you're
just so
you just have a leader energy about you
if that makes sense like it's just
you're just a leader and
leaders don't have to be you know these
like
like strong like angry warriors they can
be
these kind loving empathetic patient
graceful
uh humans and especially i don't know i
think it is just and it's also working
with
a female director it's just very it's a
very special thing
it's a very um creates a wonderful
environment
i just rambled you guys can go
everything you said was what i wanted to
say i thought that was fantastic
well done you i feel the same way i i
you have such grace and elegance and
um and you're so cool but there's no ego
in
in what you do it's all about the work
and so therefore because you were
our leader it was all about the work for
us too so we just
got in there and we did the work and it
was beautiful
and honestly like i would i want you to
direct everything
i wanna i wanna see what happens when
that when you do the world is gonna get
better
um definitely working with you you you
respected our choices
genuinely which i feel like you know i
i've struggled with before on sets i've
you know it's nerve-wracking to step
forward and say okay
i i feel like i want to do this scene
like this
what do you think and the director would
be like
okay um yeah maybe we can try that
another time
go ahead go ahead let's do it let's see
if we like it
um it was really just um like
we were both painting on the canvas
equally and that that made me feel
respected and made me feel
more open in terms of you know letting
my creativity flow within the project
as well this is a little off topic but
but all of this is reminding me because
i just recently had uh
had robin wright and connie nielsen on a
show and
both of them kept emphasizing with patty
jenkins how
she goes about getting what she wants
but without being mean about it which
sounds
super simple and i don't understand why
everybody doesn't do that but now i'm
remembering that you were an editorial
assistant on
wonder woman so what was it about
that experience working on that film
with people like that
you kind of find yourself back pocketing
and taking on to your productions now
well um wonder woman was the last studio
movie i did before i left
to direct and a big reason why was
because i
got to see how patti worked
and i had never like looked up to a
director more because she was so
calm and cool and collected and she just
spoke very
softly but carried a big stick you know
that kind of metaphor it's just
it just really rings true and you know
in the past i'd seen other directors
that were just
you know always yelling and always just
kind of throwing
things around and it was just not a fun
environment but she just made everything
so
enjoyable and calm and collaborative and
that's really the energy i wanted to
bring to my set so she's definitely a
huge role model for me
and also kind of gave me the confidence
to go off and direct
myself because i saw what she was doing
and i was like i want
to do that too and um i'm hoping
you know that i can continue in that in
that fashion
that would be a really nice note to end
on but i do have one random question
that i might be wrong on where did you
shoot this film and is that house the
house from annabelle creation
it is i feel like it's that house
it's the billy madison mansion and it's
the uh the location that the favorite
was shot i can find them in any film i
don't know what it is
that house was great though wasn't it
the little house on the prairie house
too
it was and it was also in a west world
yeah
sugar [ __ ] what was that town called
sugar hill i think so i feel like a lot
of my westworld
brain has been jumbled over the course
of the three seasons yeah it'll do that
too
and that was season one i think yeah
season one it's dolores
house oh yeah yeah please the exterior
not the interior
glad it's being uh put to good use
continually
thank you guys so much for your time
today again huge congratulations on
witch hunt everybody out there keep an
eye out for the movie on the south by
southwest schedule
like and share this video before you go
and tell everybody you know about the
movie we'll see you guys soon with more
south by content